these are desperate people who are
looking at the safety they were had come
so far experienced so much sense that
fear seeing that fear feel that
desperation I don't think they've
realized just how dangerous it was we
needed to show what these people were
going to do were these people you need
to be there
[Music]
the war was raging in Syria it was
devastating for Destruction dearme him
people cannot appreciate how it is that
war was relentless this is what these
people were running from and they were
desperate just understand why people
were leaving I mean it was rendus what
was going on there they just wanted to
get out the border between Syria and
Turkey was open at the time and so there
were literally floods of people getting
through to the coast the numbers of
people coming across into Greece and
making their way up through the Balkans
and up into Europe were thousands you
could see lines of people walking
through the fields
visuals from that were quite astonishing
[Music]
there's only a few hours by boat before
you're actually in Europe dinghies would
go over and you would get 50 people in a
dinghy most of these people weren't able
to swim
[Music]
[Music]
we had seen pictures of bodies being
washed ashore particularly one of a
small baby boy which had drawn the
attention of the world horrendous image
to comprehend and to see that picture
was the catalyst for the world's
attention
[Music]
yes Mir is normally a relatively quiet
little coastal town instead it was awash
with people wanting to cross over to
Europe the smugglers have proliferated
to such an extent that it was one of the
main industries in town like a pretty
heaving marketplace where people were
capitalizing on this mass movement of
people it was extremely profitable
extremely easy and there were plenty of
customers there was quite an industry
set up with the Turkish mafia
effectively they were buying huge
inflatable dinghies and small motors and
Counting for business in the big cities
Izmir was one when the pavements were
filled with people all with these very
very flimsy looking lifejacket almost
every hotel cafe shop was filled and
dedicated to the whole business of
people smuggling the only way to get to
to Europe was by boat that was risky but
we really thought that it was something
that we needed to show who were these
people
who were they
the whole of the town was dedicated to
making contact with people smugglers
paying people smugglers buying
lifejackets getting your position on a
dinghy
[Music]
most people were crossing on these very
flimsy inflatables and which would
ordinarily take about 10 to 15 people
and instead was being crammed full with
maybe 40 50 people they're paying
thousands of dollars each I think at the
time the going rate for your average
migrant was something like $1,200 the
boat was taking 50 odds people there
were dozens of boats going at a time
you're talking about millions of dollars
it was an entrepreneurs paradise for
smuggling there was the smuggler that
you would see the front man and then
there were those behind the scenes who
are often the Turks who are organizing
the logistics those are the ones you
wouldn't see these are serious
characters and that was something that
was very worrying for us finding a
smuggler that wasn't difficult at all
there were so many of them and they were
so readily available finding a smuggler
that would be willing to take us was
obviously an entirely different thing
names of smugglers were passed on by
word-of-mouth they were advertising the
smuggling on Facebook we have a very
strong Syrian Network these particular
individuals also have a very good
standing amongst the Syrian community
one is a former headmaster so he's very
well known in his particular area he
managed to make contact with a number of
smugglers
and then there was a different band of
smuggler who were doing it because they
wanted to help their fellow Syrians and
we managed to speak to one of the men
young men who fell into this category
my people Turkey is not a good days to
stay he was himself a migrant refugee
from the war in Syria and you expect a
smuggler to be this hard-bitten
gangster type character but he was
really very much the opposite service he
felt he was doing his duty to help
fellow Syrians effectively he was
getting but his people to safety and
whether he was right or wrong he
fervently believed that he was doing the
right thing this is really human service
he reminded me of some of my older
children
he was very idealistic he was very
artistic he was actually quite
vulnerable himself I can do that because
I can see people didn't help if you can
help someone and you don't do this you
will be bad bad people
we basically joined a group of migrants
who were taking a trip we had to meet at
night we had to pack light the cameras
are used with small secret cameras one
had to have a infrared light because I
knew I needed to keep a very low profile
we had no idea what was going to happen
once they were taken off with the other
migrants and if the smugglers were gonna
get nasty and then we were all loaded
onto these cattle trucks effectively
they were on their own we would jam
packed like sardines in a tin we had a
little bit of tarpaulin over us but it
was freezing cold and I remember
standing for about four hours trying to
get shots of this journey and everyone
was nervous and edgy
we're going into the unknown normally we
are empowered to determine where we are
going as television crews yeah we were
in the hands of the smugglers I was
experiencing exactly what these refugees
were going through we were driving
behind them in a car and Garwin was
sending me every now and again a GPS
location so that we could follow them
the one image that really stays with me
was I filmed a tarpaulin flapping in the
wind with my little secret camera and
just remember these lights as they moved
over the torn tarpaulin and it was quite
an emotive image
[Music]
we arrive again in the middle of
darkness and everyone's gets sort of
shepherded down feeling our way down
through the other groves everyone just
followed these smugglers do it
saying this way that and no talking at
all they've all just did it in quiet and
in the dark Alex and I found a tall
space and we joined a group of refugees
with us we didn't say a word we didn't
dig a way that we were I'm English
speaking when the dawn came and you were
able to see what was all around there
was loads and loads and loads of people
all over the place and they were all
sort of doze early waking up like us the
smugglers started delivering the
inflatable dinghies down to the coast
toilet
Darwyn all this time was trying to film
undercover what we didn't want to do is
to raise the alarm and to be stopped
from making the journey especially at
this point
it was quite tense because by this time
it was daylight and I'm thinking
everyone's gonna notice we don't look
Syrian as far as anyone else is
concerned we were just part of the huge
numbers of people who were trying to get
over when the boat arrived we were told
it's your turn there was a certain
amount of panic
for the migrants I don't think they
realize just how dangerous it was
until they actually got into the boat
then they were terrified they were being
rammed into these long large labels I
mean you could see grease you could see
it it was it was right across and off he
went you could just see apprehension on
their faces
they had come so far experienced so much
everyone was incredibly nervous
including ourselves as soon as we set
off we thought okay that's it we can now
bring out the cameras
and everyone went oh okay but the the
rest of the boat didn't care at that
point they just wanted to get over there
was a huge spectrum of people on board
and more desperate
this was just people fleeing for their
lives and just looking for a better life
they had sustained years of warfare and
now they just had to go and any means
possible are you feeling scared yes
the family is sitting opposite me on the
boat who the guy was a heart surgeon
from Damascus and he had come with his
whole family I said aren't you nervous
about coming on this boat because it was
obviously very crowded and a lot of them
didn't swim when he said the nervousness
about this boat is nothing compared to
the nervousness of putting up with
Assad's checkpoints and Assad's rule
they had weighed up the risk of staying
with their family in a place that was
getting bombed and where they were in
fear 24 hours a day compared with the
opportunity albeit with risks of finally
reaching some safety and freedom thank
you
we were unsure whether our team would
make it through or not
one problem was the capsizing the other
problem was getting taken by the Turkish
or the Greek Coast Guard this huge
vessel comes into sight
[Music]
they kept on coming really close to rock
the ding-ding they try to capsize our
boat by causing a huge weight it was a
much bigger vessel so every time they
came close the wash would throw the
dunya
the decks were crammed with refugees
which they had apprehended already and
we were the next
we were not crossing and this was the
example that the Turks were going to
give to all those other boats they
weren't going to make this journey easy
and they picked on us
the surgeon was telling them to leave us
alone
he just started leading the chanting and
the shouting at them
we went from apprehension to fear to
anger
they were so angry they had come so far
had experienced so much only to be
stopped in the middle of the city
they were not gonna have it they will
not gonna stop and they'll say to me
form the phone full don't stop feeding
the coastguard kept shouting to stop
turn round and people on the boat kept
on shouting to the skipper to keep going
the skipper's had nerves of steel and
just was literally powering ahead
[Music]
the danger of capsizing was very very
real
if the dingey tipped
that would have been awful we knew we
had to have a contingency plan the plan
was for us to get a boat and try and
follow them out to sea in case the
dinghy capsized sank
we would have ditched everything when
you dumped all the equipment didn't you
wouldn't worry about that but how are we
gonna save 40 other people obviously our
primary concern is to rescue you Alex
and garlic but they were with a whole
host of other migrants who we couldn't
just leave in the water so we were ready
to pick up as many people as we could we
were now the refugees so we had to leave
it to fate as to what would happen when
we were in the fishing boat coming up
behind them we could see there was a
Coast Guard ship we were terrified that
they were going to get picked up
[Music]
as they came very close to us they
noticed Darwin using his camera Nick
just enraged the coastguard
even more and then we heard the gunshot
started firing in the air and pointing
guns at us we became really very very
worried about what was happening to me
and they started holding up their babies
to show look we've got babies on board
and I was forming over time and it was
incredibly emotional even though
sometimes you disassociate yourself when
you're performing
my emotions were heightened at this very
moment I thought it was over for us
within a few moments we seemed to be
over the Coast Guard just pulled away oh
my word the euphoria was unbelievable
they were cheering they were shouting
Arabic words of celebration I had become
a refugee I was caught up in that
emotion as well
thank you Thank You Lora
hamdulillah they were filled with
emotion and gratitude their voices were
cracking as they were answering my
questions
I remember being kissed on the cheek
thinking that for some reason that I had
mean and one of the reasons why the boat
had let us through I wanted everyone in
Europe to hear them hear how how
grateful they were that this body of
people had somehow opened up their
collective arms and given them a second
chance of life because that's how they
viewed it
[Music]
we heard that they got through and that
was just such an unbelievable relief I
couldn't believe it in fact I was get
absolutely convinced that the [ __ ] was
either going to go down the boat was
either going to go down or they were
gonna get picked up as we got closer to
the shore they couldn't wait and people
started jumping off swimming to the
shores they were so delighted it
literally has doom in their haste just
to get to Europe
this isn't freedom
[Music]
[Applause]
as we beach the boat they they grabbed
the skip of the boat and hoisted him on
his shoulders and threw him up into the
air
[Music]
and I thought we've only done a tiny
portion of their journey and we felt
drained absolutely drained of everything
it was so difficult to turn our backs on
them and say goodbye we thought as if we
were letting them down abandoning them
and that was quite difficult all the
other people started walking up the hill
and we stood we started walking with
them and we went round a corner and
there was a huge huge pile of life
jackets literally with hundreds and
hundreds of discarded life jackets and I
thought that that that's the number of
people have been round here in the last
few days maybe
it was a very controversial decision
being on that boat this was a calculated
risk we needed to show what these people
were going through and what it took to
do what they were doing and what it
meant for them to take on these perilous
journeys and I think that was achieved
and it did turn people's minds appear to
make them realize that actually these
aren't just people looking for a better
economic life these are desperate people
who are looking for safety and looking
for a chance to survive people smuggling
is huge and wherever there are desperate
people and desperate situations to run
away from there will be others who will
make money from you initially there was
sympathy now there's a lot of animosity
towards them which is pretty unfortunate
no one really knows what they are
fleeing and what they have experienced
which is horrific
[Music]